hi everybody we're alive i thought i was
live for a second and i was just talking
aimlessly to the camera yeah
but now we're now we're live i think so
welcome to the stream this is going to
be a
truly revealing maybe even historic one
where um
your your humble hosts will answer any
questions coming towards us and they
don't have to be
personally
connected to us they can be anything you
can ask about world history
sound like a game show host
well that's what we are can you guys
hear okay
yeah
yeah you guys can hear okay
um
yeah pretty bold to hold the name
you know i was considering um
not doing it but i thought you know i i
just got to do it for the love of the
game you know
and if it makes things harder for the
feds then
then that's that's fine okay audio was
fine
how long was the jurassic period don't
ask that i i don't know that
who was alexander the great who i don't
know
do you know uh-huh who was he
our neighbor right
he was our neighbor guys
uh what's wrong with your hair
you know i didn't shower
and probably my hair
no your hair looks good
i didn't shower and i woke up so that's
kind of what happens uh who's the first
president of the united states
[Music]
was it bill clinton
he was one of them i think
what are you doing honey oh i'm just
testing
i like this question someone said when
will you get a cat
honey you want to answer that
we said we would answer unhinged
questions
and i think it's only fair that you
answer it
it's not pick and choose questions you
know you have to answer it
right right um i'm not going gonna
answer it uh did you finish song with
susannah when is the review coming i'm
actually almost on the song of susanna
um i kind of jump around reading and it
also depends on what um
with work and stuff so i've been working
uh
a night job a temporary thing um
so it's
i my reading schedule is a little weird
because i'm reading all sorts of stuff
during my breaks
um
uh
look at that thanks potato yeah thank
you
what is your favorite cooking utensil
favorite cooking utensil
um probably a whisk
mine is
none because i like to cook with my
hands
how do you co
don't wouldn't you like hurt your hands
no
i'm just cool like that
um
yeah so
uh
i i like a whisk because first off great
verb and you can use whisk away right
love it and whisks you know
scramble some eggs
love that whisk
um
what is the best tool to escape from
prison
are you allowed to say it no no no no no
that'd be spoilers for season two um
am i going to kill joshua for real now
um
you know a guy can hope and dream
um
what are we at
uh gorb
hey gorb um i love this
thank you gorb
getting the cat fun going early
yes
i love gorb uh what a
what a kind
individual but um
to be perfectly frank gorbo we're gonna
get a cat that's what's that what the
hell
perfectly frank gorb has been harassing
me for months about cats okay look at
the cute kitty on the profile i know
it's a cute it's cute that's gorb
gorba's little cat
um
do i read web novels no i don't i like
that question wolves or dragons hold on
what is nadia made of
i am made of
peppers
and a little salt
we gotta mix it really well and then you
get naughty in the morning
okay someone said please do record your
reaction when i finish the dark tower um
i can do that yeah just set up a camera
i love those reading vlogs where people
are like setting up the camera and
they're like i'm just gonna record in
case i cry
i do that with you i just record you i
just stalk you
document when you you know go on trial
again what
what
oh okay
um
let's see um what was that wolves or
dragons
um
i like
dragon
i thought like i used to i was used to
say wolves but like the dragons on game
of thrones are so cute
i wouldn't you don't think so no no no
no no no no no aren't you supposed to be
in prison also the answer is spork
sporks um are you kidding me don't don't
even talk to me about sports i don't
want to hear that
uh sports are a waste of time
it's just like people say oh you're
combining the best part of a sport of a
spoon and a fork right no what you're
doing is you're putting the worst parts
of spoons and forks together all right
the worst part of a fork
is combined with the worst part of the
spoon it's just
nothing gets happy okay it's weird
synergy
um
any opinions on sports i'd like to talk
about this for a few more minutes i
conquer
so concise um
can i watch attack on titan yeah
have you seen it no i haven't we could
watch it what is in the mug um tears the
tears of my enemies yeah
also coffee i think
with spiked it says misses at the other
end
yeah of course
why wouldn't it
um
see yeah my mom got it for us after we
got married do i have whisks in multiple
sizes obviously i'm not what is this
amateur hour
um
what is the test
what oh what about my words what is the
best cat breed
um
i don't know any cat personality i like
i like rescues
yeah
um
but but you know there's hypo allergenic
ones if you're allergic to cats so
uh what thing is man carrying don't
don't don't how do we remove people from
chat
um
is that a biden joke about you know the
thing i'm not familiar who is biden
is that your dad
thought that was your dad's middle name
biden no
oh
huh
are you gonna pay our pension i don't
know if you are familiar with how like
employment works
sam's speechless but i don't that's not
really how it works um
it's it's really sad that we don't have
pensions anymore
okay
just things are getting more and more
deranged cat cat cat as we go along yes
can we get a cat on chat no but we have
a dog on chat you want to see our dogs
oh she's resting hey come here
she's wearing clothes this is our cat
dog
she she's a fancy dog
she's such a cutie
um
what's
on your guys minds these days oh you
want to go back
what's on our mind
oh man
my mind is i wish that i was like i wish
i had powers
what kind of powers
every power that ever exists
i want to dictate the world
and i want to see people crawl on their
feet
and beg for mercy
i didn't say that
she didn't say that
that was interesting did you
black out there for a second yeah i
think i blacked out
i'll tell you what's on my mind these
days
um
doom uh we just got hbo max recently
yeah i'm like uh but i i don't know i
still want to see dune in theaters but
then again it's so easy and simple to
see
on hbo max
um
tiger king two got it i haven't even
seen tiger king first season guys
i'm so out of the loop
um okay all right we got okay i'll go
back in the chat what holiday do you all
get most excited for i always like
decorating for halloween personally
potato
that yeah thanks potato i always love
seeing your profile picture i feel like
i'm looking at our reflection
we're very similar looking uh what
holiday uh halloween period i like
christmas too
no no halloween is the best
christmas i love christmas i love like
the holiday times periods just seeing
all the lights everywhere
and then
just being able to you can have
halloween lights and they're orange and
it's awesome and you know you watch the
halloween movies are the best movies uh
scary movies
so much range and i just love it so much
um what did you do i did what did you
do okay
um
parent or matt best boy
um
well best boy is uh an important part in
a film set they're typically the number
two to
like the key grip or something like that
so i would say based on their skill in
the film industry neither because i
don't think they're familiar with any
film
technology
uh but the best boy is an important an
underrated uh job on a film set
but if i had to choose
um parent at this at this point in the
series right paren yeah
um what do you mean yeah i've heard
about it oh [ __ ] you talked to me about
it you go parent parent parent in your
sleep
what are your names uh my name is jake
deborah
no deborah no deborah no debra nadia
deborah okay
um when does despacito 2 come out i feel
like there's a google search um
what have i lost of the live stream uh
just a lot of happiness and joy
man caring one caring dog
i'm trying hard not to ask about that
thing that's good uh that's good have i
read his dark materials i haven't that's
one that's been uh a must read for me
though
um have i ever been to portugal no but
i've really wanted to uh for a long time
it's it's
um i had a chance to go to portugal when
i did study abroad in spain but yeah but
you didn't go to portugal didn't you did
you i went to france oh she went to
france so much better huh they're both
great no portugal is better
i assume
um i don't know
uh placeholder sent 4.99 thanks
placeholder thank you for place holding
that fortnite yeah what place are you
holding
um
how do you clean your books
um i
like an any sane person i don't i just
dust them what um yeah have i been
cleaning your books wrong
i didn't say that i don't clean his
books
okay all right don't worry guys we're
we're going back
through the chat foundation is coming
yeah i need to watch uh foundation um
because i think the first season came
out uh
i love doing as well
i have already seen dune and cinema how
was it i'm
i'm so excited
um
um
urine and feces are processed in the
thigh pan
am i reading that right
[Laughter]
um
yeah yeah
do we get halloween stream with costumes
um i'll be working on halloween night so
probably not i will be getting yeah you
can stream if you want
we'll just have solo nadia stream um
it's my opinion on eggs great love them
i have a question yes
so
during halloween or the holiday season
do you guys find it uh like pick certain
amount of books like halloween related
or holiday related books or do you just
finish like what you intended to finish
previous to that
was that for a chat
yeah i want to know oh yeah yeah i guess
that was a loaded question but
yeah come on chad okay while you guys
are answering
i'm gonna answer favorite horror movie
do you have a favorite horror movie
yes every horror movie i watch
that is such a non-answer it's
disgusting because i don't really watch
horror movies all the way i closed my
eyes for half of it yeah we watched evil
dead um
my god it was so scary i didn't think it
was going to be scary because it was
like oh this movie was made like years
ago
yeah it's
it's sort of cheesy but it's still
creepy it's very creepy
and you had your eyes closed for about
half of it
yeah
you know what i used to do when i was a
teenager
i used to like because i was always
scared or like i was always easily
scared so i used to wear a hat whenever
i went to a theater
and i used to like laugh at horror films
because all i could do is hear things
and
people would be like oh my god you don't
get scared at all i'm like no those
scenes are so funny
but i really wasn't watching it yeah
miss those times when i used to like
fool people
um
ever read any cormac mccarthy yes i have
i don't believe you have
um
blood meridian is an amazing book
um
official character oh sorry i didn't
answer my favorite horror movie um
probably uh the shining or
um
halloween
um
why are there only 34 people here i
don't know i see more i see i see more
than that
um how do you clean your books
i think i answered that favorite stephen
king novel currently um it is probably
the wastelands
um
all right all right all right i'm going
through chat i'm going through um
what's my full id current location you
have any wounds and are you armed i will
email you
about that
um
let's see
how do you make a grilled cheese
with just a hand yeah how do you do that
you just have to have super hand
or you just burn scald your hands yeah
you have to have a super hand yeah
please call me place mr holder was my
father
[Laughter]
uh
i know
um
super sticker
i love i love super sticker thanks uh
thank you um
uh number one fan
um
yeah super is a super sticker like a
thing that you can do yeah i think so
i'm a little um slow to the thank you
uh lol nadia is a trickster you could
say that she pranks me all the freaking
time
he hates
pranks well when they're psychological
tortured i i hate them i like fun pranks
you know
like you know a pie to the face
hereditary is my favorite horror
hereditary is
gives me nightmares like
and it wasn't even that i didn't even
think the ending was scary or anything
it's just that scene you know the scene
that scene
you haven't seen it no but it it like
made me depressed i watched it remember
it forwarded through it yeah oh she
watches movies by like watching 10
minutes of it by fast forwarding through
it
that not the call awesome thing on your
phone yeah
it grinds my gears grinds my kids guys
um but hereditary that scene oh my god
um uh yeah are you still uh crossed with
peter jackson are you ready to forgive
him um yeah uh i'm still very um upset
with peter i was i don't know if you
guys saw the new video today but i was
fired
from the lord of the rings set i was a a
key grip uh
viggo kept trying to hit me with the
stupid orc head when he was kicking it
uh but everyone was concerned about vigo
i lost my job i lost my job all right
it's a long time ago i'm still mad about
it speaking of joshua
jake has an instagram now
um oh oh yeah
instagram guys um
just go go
but okay whatever you guys are doing
right now i know you're watching but
also open that other tab or whatever and
follow me on instagram because um didn't
post the link in there i don't know how
right here
no
i
no
right here stop
here
right here no
i don't know how
i don't know how
fine all right yeah so go follow me on
instagram if you want um
uh let's see
too many books okay blah blah blah uh
this year i want to watch training yeah
i actually haven't seen that uh
predatory yeah
should i read the dark tower or do i
have to read other kings books to enjoy
the series um no you just go straight
into the tower you can totally read
other king's books they will enhance the
experience i personally think you should
read salem's lot at least
before book five
but you don't even have to do that
because it's summarized in book five but
yeah the books are fantastic they stand
on their own can you watch the show
salem
uh that's what salem's not like the
miniseries
no sabrina
um
not this no what she's a witch okay uh
is the time near i get ignored this is
the guy do you know this guy
this is the guy who taunts me about this
stand yeah and i still haven't read the
stand
guys i'll read the stand
i'll read the stand at some point but
this person terrifies me
um do you know there's a man carrying
thing discord yeah thank you for
spreading awareness they have some crazy
times in there i um you know they they
they meme around i don't know it's it's
scary it's kind of frightening in there
but sometimes i i'll go in there and
impart my wisdom you know
um because i am technically the god of
the server
um yeah
best city in the wheel of time
uh i don't know why but carrion is like
my favorite carhen care something like
that i forget what it's called um
pancakes or crepes
i mean crepes are just really thin
pancakes
i will ignore that you said that
i love
swedish pancakes which look like
crepes
people who hate pranks are praised
favorites perfect match
that's so true yeah oh my god so when we
first got together i used to prank him
all the time
and he hated it so now i don't do
anymore uh she does um not like that
if you could cosplay anything for
halloween from fantasy what would that
be i mean wit obviously i think i've
talked about this
uh 50k subs we're doing wood cosplay at
least i am
i'm going to go
all right i'm announcing it here and i
hope this doesn't get screen grabbed or
something but it probably will
50k subs i'm going to dress up as wit go
down to hollywood boulevard
and uh
and do stand up as wit on the street
yeah and people are going to give me
money and they're going to take pictures
with me
uh i'm going to be like a spider-man i'm
going to be like hanging out with
spider-man and superman guys dressed up
on hollywood boulevard except i'll be
wit and people will be like
wanting to take pictures with me they'll
know who i am
that's a good idea right
yes that's
that's that's your idea
what's your opinion on the hit 2009
movie uh by james cameron avatar
what do you think about it oh
so okay
i'm obsessed with avatar the animation
the animated series um
and i like i like the new avatar too
um
but the movie i just like feel like they
took out all the humor that i loved
about the show
like it was like let's make avatar we're
talking about james cameron or
avatar the last airbender
oh my god one thing i think they're
talking about james cameron's avatar
well never mind but anyway i hated never
mind
i like that one
the avatar the last airbender was pretty
bad the m night shyamalan
right
yes
sure
[Laughter]
it's okay fictional character you don't
want to meet in real life
i don't want to meet uh rock because
they say don't meet your heroes what
about you
you know i didn't want to meet you but
here we are
i'm not fictional
what okay here we go again
here we go again what do we do if we run
into joshua in the wild you know what to
do look i can't say
technically i can't say on you know
stream what you should do but i think
you know what you should do
i should do like i think you know maybe
like
ask him to text me back
no
how's the cat coming along jake it's not
it's not it is there better not be more
of this cat talk i love this because
slowly maturely like we're just taking
away little will of him to you know have
a stand against cat a little bit a
little bit picking it a little bit apart
until he's just a man without no thing
without a thing
uh lord of the rings or harry potter
come on guys lord of the rings
both
can't pick it it's like choosing between
my right or the left hand what
i i fall asleep and now that we have um
hbo max i was watching harry potter and
fell asleep to it
i never realized how deathly hollow part
1 though was boring
it's so boring because it was just like
so obvious that they
made part 1 and part two to kind of like
get the most out of it since it's the
last book
it's just like barely anything happened
in part one
uh yeah i don't know the pacing ever
since after from six through eight of
the movies the pacing got messed up the
tone got messed up there was way more
humor in the earlier movies all right
movie number four best one all right
movie number four for the best one
mine's the last one kick that voldemort
to the curve
what do you think about chris pratt
playing mario in a movie by old see to
me illuminate first off illumination
what illumination is the best studio
ever nothing beats illumination it is
they make the best quality movies ever
made and um
better than like act than like other
like jaws better than jaws okay and
chris pratt when i play mario uh and
i've been playing mario for a long time
when i play i always picture chris
pratt's
um voice in my head all right he's the
perfe he's the person i always think of
chris pratt i'm like perfect person to
play mario period
i do not that is not what i think at all
well i'm just i'm you know i just think
of joshua
did you know that there's an old poem
titled man caring thing
um coincidence no yeah there is uh
wallace stephen's poem called man caring
thing and it was uh the namesake for
this channel you guys should read it's
good paul um
uh
started book four what no not yet guys
okay first off
just to be
upfront with you all i'm been insanely
busy because i'm starting new quarter
and i started a new job uh which
it's temporary job but it's
long hours through all parts of the
night so i'm a bit uh
highly caffeinated and sleep deprived
these days so
um if the videos are getting more and
more surreal and um nonsensical during
this time period don't worry they'll
start to get make more sense later on
but like
if you watch last night's video i'm sure
you'll understand
um
spooky instagram
um do you ever think about the books you
want to read and have an extra
existential crisis or is that just me of
course
wait do you ever think about the books
you want to read and have it
oh yeah
i think that's every book lover
um
why
are you so cute i think i think they're
talking about me um yes why am i so cute
i just am
you know that whole like hatred for
joshua just gets him so riled up and he
just wants to like
channel his cuteness out have you
started book nine of wheel of time
i have so much rage
have you started book 14 of real time uh
i'm getting closer
will you drop out of college and move to
the jungle for a period of time i mean
that's always been my intention
he already lives in the jungle whenever
i'm mad at him
uh did you start interneting for pazuzu
uh interneting what is this 1995
i don't actually know what year is it
1996. it's 1996 guys
um you would think though yeah the
videos never made sense no worries you
would think that like you know jake is
born in like 1950s
um
in a bad i mean not in a bad way in a
good way
yeah that doesn't sound good
in a good way like it's a good thing um
people talk about old souls
is there actually any trauma between you
and daniel
like for real no
what i know about the flare talk i know
all the lawyer talk but for real guys
don't tell anyone but um daniel's
actually a very nice person
very sweet and supportive content
creator who has helped this channel a
ton
but don't tell anyone that obviously
um
have i started a book for
um
that's the best one yeah when um
that's the one where right after
everyone destroys the ring they all just
die book 42 of wheel of time uh
unfortunately no
uh will you see dune when it comes on
october of course i've i'll probably
watch it in theaters and on hbo prime
perhaps give me water but you know what
i'm really also excited for is halloween
kills
because
i love the halloween series
and um
it's just halloween kills looks good i
really like the halloween 2018 remake i
thought or not a remake reboot whatever
soft reboot they did a good job with
that um
so halloween kills looks pretty bloody
fun
um
stormlight five have i started
stormlight five yet uh i actually no
uh i haven't
but um i'm i'm i'm looking to i mean
brandon emailed me he said you know i i
wrote stormlight5 you're the only one
who's allowed to read it
um so we'll see
what is the worst book you've both read
more than once
what
i have
have i don't think i've any
if it's a bad book i don't even finish
it you would because for school
well yeah
like if you read something in high
school really have to read it yeah read
in school
i was a good student so i read it
uh
probably like well it's not a bad book
but probably like the odyssey
the uh are you crapping on the odyssey
right now like the most important like
text
oh my god all right
i read it in middle school high school
college i was kind of done you know
got it done
uh what is the longest you will ever
grow your hair you
me yeah
um well my hair is like down to my mid
waist right now and i kind of want to
cut it so probably there
it's just it's it's a lot it's a lot
it's a lot me i'll probably i don't know
i hate getting my hair cut so i used to
have my hair pretty long in
high school so when you went to san
francisco i think that was a long time
when i lived in san francisco it was
pretty long so i don't know we'll see
we'll see how it goes
um
favorite position to read books in
[Laughter]
i would like to read on the floor i like
to
i like to sit on his head and read there
he doesn't love me
yeah that's kind of strange
um
twitter judges your bookshelf video is
my favorite thank you i like that video
um
yeah um let's see let's see what's your
opinion on you and consume
uh physical material
um like food like having to like have a
body and be like a
physical on this realm of existence and
needing to like sustain myself and exist
yeah it it sucks i'm not gonna lie about
it it's a pain in the ass
your opinion
uh yeah
you know i really wish more than
anything more than any food because food
is really good
um i really wish that i didn't need to
sleep
someone said why are you drinking out of
a fish tank
um
have i read carmen punishment no i have
not
um
that's what i need to be doing
um
your internet is failing you i'll be
going for now um
all right but i'll hold it against you
personally
who was grug wash
washing a ton um i'm not exactly sure
but i think it was greg washingtonian
oh oh he was president during civil war
all right that's right
least favorite character in wheel of
time so far
hmm
let me think about it yeah i'll let you
think about it let me think nothing
really stands out as oh um um what's her
name
the the lady that is obviously evil that
rand meets in the forest um or in um
in the portals during
no you guys know what i'm saying
um i killed someone how would i hide the
body uh
i think you guys are aware of that yeah
uh big canyon um but that's just
hypothetical obviously
um
what is your favorite movies from the
80s
hmm
i haven't really thought about specific
decade um
i don't know so many interesting movies
from the 80s
i can't remember where
little house that prairie the movies
were in the 70s or 80s
probably both
yeah i really liked those growing up
it was wholesome
it was hashtag wholesome
it was hashtag hold the sum
hashtag
hold
hold the hole
anyway
um yeah the shining is my favorite from
the 80s although it was probably it was
filmed probably mostly in the 70s but
came out in the 80s um
finished elrond hubbard's technology it
sucked and was home yeah
i mean
you read 10 books that you hated i mean
i guess that's an achievement but have
you watched
scientology
the aftermath what
kind of reminds me of that scientist
well he invented scientology right yeah
that's why yeah why are you acting like
that's such a shock
it's shocking
um
it's pretty wild reading the odyssey
from english class that is just american
yeah i know that was that's what the
critics said at the time too they were
like homer we love this but odysseus
kind of a mary sue
um
the most important pieces in the
literature and all the fantasy yeah the
others was kind of boring
oh someone said what is our favorite
school or what is our school major i
think i missed
oh yeah what is our school major um
english yeah we're both english majors
digital humanities minor yeah she
graduated um i'm graduating next year
[Music]
oh yeah the
the amiad is total fan fiction uh it's
so so annoying but pretty good though
okay
um
wife and i are reading uh will chime and
love watching your reviews of the book
we actually are keeping up with you
surprisingly
hey thank you uh new review coming out
hopefully week after next
we'll see uh most annoying habit of our
partner uh don't fight
oh
i want to take my time with this
huh
okay don't think too hard
uh
probably
um
okay
probably how he like
doesn't like audiobooks and always like
criticizes it and doesn't even give it a
try in order to criticize it i have
given it a try also
um
when he wakes up in the morning
and
he like needs coffee instantly but waits
to drink coffee
you know
and then complains about not having
coffee but then doesn't want coffee
right away
also when he has a headache and then he
doesn't want to drink water but then he
complains about having a headache
just just hold my hand i was going to
say your most annoying habit is that
you're perfect but
yeah
oh
yeah exactly i bet you feel guilty now
it's one of
your most annoying habits reverse
psychology yeah
love your stormlight uh thank you uh
opinion on anime or manga um i'm i'm
down with it but i haven't i have a
little experience with it um
i love anime i don't want to go out with
my friends give me an excuse oh what's a
good excuse um just say that you don't
like them say that they're bad people
you don't want to be around them no i
have a great excuse what
say that you're currently killing your
partner
um that's always a good one i'm trying
to hide the body
and then bring them bring them and tell
them like ask them to be their your
alibi and they're just not gonna want to
be friends with you
say you're watching man carrying thing
uh stream that that'll that'll fix it up
hello my lord how are you doing oh i
like the formality
yeah that's pretty nice i'm sure you do
i'm doing fantastic
i haven't read leviathan weights yet um
heaviest do i read milky yeah
have you does anyone watch super natural
they have little biathans in there
so lean yeah celine is the one i'm
talking about
yeah i i wasn't a fan
um
jake it's the police they're outside
with the sirens um
no it's uh probably the fire department
from that arson i did i mean
ironically right i meant that ironically
uh stephen king book uh i feel like i
keep getting asked that um i i said the
wastelands i think i really like the
wastelands um
every time jacob hears the ambulance
sirens he hopes joshua i mean joshua
doesn't live near me but maybe
um
do i listen to rock yeah i well i love
rock he makes great soup
it's my favorite soup um tomato yours
uh butternut butternut squash yeah
um
let's see just started watching your
channel recently and have been really
enjoying the content
someone asked me my destiny i'm nepali
nadia is uh nepali yeah
and um
we've been meaning to go to nepal
soon but because of
probably the world yeah yeah i'm very
excited um
okay i saw somewhere in there i think
you scroll past it or what happened
someone asked me my favorite anime and
honestly i can't wait to talk about it
because dragon balls
dragon balls
dragon ball z
oh it's a dragon balls or dragon ball z
they're two different series oh okay
they're two different series and then
there's i don't know anything about it
it's dragon ball
but like
it
there's dragon ball dragon ball z dragon
ball super but dragon ball z was the
best
with vegeta
hmm
well yeah i think i've seen some of it
um i'm team vegito
if you know what i mean
why did your incompetent lawyer fail to
get you out i was the lawyer guys i was
the lawyer don't call me incompetent i
did a good job self-trained university
of phoenix online
god have i learned right lines no i
haven't but i do have um another guy
giver okay on my bookshelf
waiting to be read um
why didn't you tell me i need to know
spanish straight blood marine you don't
need to know spanish but it might help a
little bit because there are some pages
with spanish but it you really don't
it's not totally necessary
um
uh what is your most controversial
opinion about something mundane
um
oh i think
people well i don't know if it's mundane
but people who don't use their turn
signal are basically evil
because
it's one of the sim it's literally the
tiniest little thing you can do you
could cause so many accidents that way
and kill people that way and it's like
if i die because someone didn't turn on
their blinker and i just ran into them
i would be way more mad than somebody if
like you know
that's just that's just it's so dumb
just use your blinker mine is when
people go to my bathroom and wash their
hands and i have like a cloth in there
for them to walk the sink after and they
don't do it
is that a jab at me
um who do you think lizzo or willem
dafoe is taller
um
yeah
that is uh age-old question uh i'm gonna
wager i'm gonna say lizzo is taller plus
she probably has heels so
i'm gonna say she's taller than william
defoe on a normal day
um
watch one piece i may be reading one
piece i want to read it with him
that'd be fun yes um
uh what did i
we do wrong for you to unleash covert i
hate to say it but i was not responsible
for that
i know a lot of people are trying to do
that uh pin that on me pablo i love
pablo if you could go back in time to
the signing of the declaration of
independence what would you tell the
founding fathers to throw in there with
the mix
um oh man that's a serious question
this is a real serious question um
i would i would tell them to maybe just
like re do try it all again maybe how
about you don't say just man you know
woman also yeah and how about
you know the whole slavery thing and you
know killing native americans and you
know
maybe they could yeah i would just be
like guys maybe first draft not the best
you know we all need to look over our
work so let's try draft two maybe draft
do a few drafts
constitution also um
my partner reads way more than me how do
i cope
i
i cope by
just like
you know eating
while he reads more than me
i just eat
and then
it doesn't help
all right so
what bender would jake be though oh like
firebender waterbender yes i don't know
what would i be
uh you would be earthbender
why
because honey you move mountains
with the sound of your voice you're a
firebender
[Laughter]
also fire bending is so much cooler and
that's what i hated about the actual
movie that they took out because like in
the series um the show
you know you could do you can create
fire through your hands or your body in
a show they needed like
an outside source to create fire with
water bending
in the original series you need to
actually be near water to bend it or
you know
so
um
with earth bending i guess like you're
always surrounded by earth but i don't
know
it's still
i guess earth bending would be cool
because i just you know make myself a
free house that i don't have to pay rent
for in a forest and it'll be like a
luxurious house
um here's a question which are your
hogwarts houses
i am
gryffindor i was gonna say like you know
what
i hated
have you ever read the um
the quote-unquote eighth book it's a
play
um
yeah the cursed child yeah
yeah and it was like all about like
slytherin
like anti-slytherin kind of thing and it
kind of made me feel bad for slytherin
even though they were pretty bad
but you know
yeah hogwarts
feel like the the cursed child ruin the
series
um i would say i'm a hufflepuff though
there's nothing wrong with being a
hufflepuff they're good okay cedric
diggory was hufflepuff and he dies yeah
but people like him yeah but hey harry
was a chosen one how dare you skip
comments i'm sorry
most annoying thing ever when he looks
through comments i kind of jump up and
down yeah scattered this is kind of how
my brain works
or wastelands the you know these books
are compared to each other all the time
so there's a totally reasonable question
um
moby dick
um had i come up with the channel's name
um i was reading wallace stevens and i
was like oh that'd be cool because he
has some great poem titles
um
so i thought that'd be kind of fun to
use one um
someone said at the very end like cursed
child like the jk uh
jk rowing ruined the series yeah she did
you know also like her tweets like even
before the whole controversial stuff was
that like she would say she would like
go against the series like hey before
they had toilets people used to be able
to just swish their poop away it's like
why would they want to have a toilet and
then do that that's way better people
used to just [ __ ] their pants
[Laughter]
yeah
and then they're like no this is kind of
weird we i kind of get that
but it's still like weird it's like
there's like slytherin which is very
anti-muggle but at the same time they
want to adopt toilets and then how does
that go into pipeline like with the
whole
slytherin guy like you know using the
pipeline for the snake and chamber of
secrets just a lot of
holes just good enough be good enough
okay here's a question if there was only
one piece of media you could enjoy why
would it be family guy five paragraph
essay due tomorrow okay thanks
um
i actually don't want to answer this i
don't know why i'm highlighting it if
there was
this is a cursed comment
so basically you're saying that only i
don't don't interact don't engage with
them don't don't give them attention for
that um did i like the doctor sleep
movie uh i love family guy by the way
did did you like the doctor sleep movie
um i haven't seen it because i've been
waiting to read the uh dr sleep book
first um
but i i like uh mike flanagan we watched
haunting of blind manor hunting of hill
house i really liked haunting the blind
manor um
although i had to force him to watch it
but she did but i liked it i liked it um
all right we're getting some
controversial takes
um gryffindor was the correct answer
don't talk about the play
uh don't make us bully into reading one
yeah i know it's been done before but
that's not going to happen with me i'm
uh you guys can't bully me okay you try
bullying me with cats and i just become
more resistant i'm a stubborn i'm a
stubborn just wait just wait we're gonna
have a cat no
yeah
um
um why would joshua
why would okay why would joshua give you
a job at the farmer field i didn't even
have that at uh i was just uh
i was just a student at the time
uh i guess he was toying with me um
cursed child rough okay hufflepuff good
see
okay
okay okay first off that's not a great
accola like oh you're a good finder
hey where are the car keys oh i'm a
hufflepuff i'll find him well i always
ask you to find my phone
yeah you lose
all the time in that case i am good at
finding things but when i'm like hungry
for food i can't find crap in the fridge
um
let's see
okay all right he skipped my comment
about how he skips all my comments it's
all good there are a lot of comments
i am sorry but i'm i'm i'm not skipping
this comment because um
i think i need to be called out for my
crimes
oh
i just i jump all over the place so i'm
sorry if i miss your comment i might
return to it who knows um
ravenclaw ravenclaws don't don't even
with me with you ravenclaws all right
you think you're better than everyone
you probably are but yeah
um
let's see
the uh child is just cursed i know i see
it i see it i see it i see it
okay
okay
gorb please don't read one piece focus
on getting cats
oh my gosh gorb
you know
the amount of
currency going into us getting a cat is
just phenomenal i mean it it makes me
want to not get a cat even more my god
[Laughter]
gorb we love you but you terrify me to
no end um
and um
chris child best one in the series yeah
that's what i think huh
uh
in my head uh anything after the public
last book is not economical yeah yeah i
agree with you pablo we do not stand um
anything after
i mean i don't know it's complicated
relationship with the books because of
the author but uh you can try if you can
separate author from from the art
um
well pablo like you're from the uk so i
want to ask you like is it the same kind
what's the sentiment around rowing
it's curious what what's the sentiment
yeah oh general well that she's
transphobic and uh
bigoted and uh
horrible said horrible things
yeah that's
what it is around here i just want to
ask just in case
um
let's see hufflepuffs are good finders
yeah i know i know
one one piece or a cat you have to
choose at least one see the both are big
movements
but i bet one piece has a cat
um
now i'm really excited to read one piece
favorite sitcoms oh my god there's
couple there's different ones oh okay
so for me
friends
30 rock
fresh prince of bel air
30 rock is one of my all-time favorites
yeah i like fresh prince of ballarat i
haven't seen it in a while though
because
i don't know if it's in streaming that
we have
i don't know actually um
but
i know okay there's it's not technically
a sitcom
but barry because it's like there's
drama in it so i i don't consider it a
real sitcom
but it's so freaking funny barry is
great
there's just one episode
with this little girl who does karate oh
my god you have to swatch it
yeah uh barry is so good um i would for
me um
my
i love community um
but but it's not like a laugh track
sitcom for laughtrack.com probably
probably like seinfeld but um
let's i've never seen seinfeld
we gotta watch it it's coming to netflix
soon
um
i need to know whether you love hamilton
if not why are you a bad person hamilton
is has good um really good music
and i don't think you're a bad person if
you don't like hamilton because it is
very problematic you know and just the
whole concept is
suspect
but uh it does have very very good music
i cannot deny that i like it um
um what in the world were you on when
you came up with the whole josh mere
storyline love you jake uh i love you
too harsh reviews you know joshua is
actually my my one true love
all right so but for real though
uh for real uh there was no planning i
just made a video i thought it'd be
funny if i pretended like i was um
doing a regular book review guy who was
just excited about books but who just
recently got divorced and then it i just
liked how people reacted to that video
and i mismade it a series and now it's
gotten to the point where
i'm escaping from the police
um
and murder is involved
um have i ever thought about writing
your own book uh
yeah all the time
well he's actually
he's already like written um some stuff
he's writing a novel
he's on like chapter four or five
and it is so
freaking good
and it's just you just need to write
more of it but it's so good same goes
for her she's an excellent writer and
she's um
currently writing working on a book so
it's and it's very good so um we're both
writers so
yeah i like to write about joshua
no you don't
you know
um
if you were hyper hypothetically going
to kill joshua for a second time not
that you did it the first time how would
you do it
um
that's i guess i should write a book
about that but if i were to do it i
would push him off you better not canyon
i would lure him to the grand canyon
with promise for really good dodgers
tickets he loves the dodgers and i would
be like hey he want the tickets on the
tickets go fetch and he'd be like wow
that was really rude is it and then i
pushed him off the grand canyon but
that's if i did which i wouldn't ever
hufflepuff is a famous brand of
cigarettes in the wizarding world and as
well know
smoking isn't cool kids thank you overly
average men wonderful overly average ben
great channel we love them but um
smoking exactly it's not cool it looks
cool but it's not you know it's not good
for you it looks badass
but it's not good unless it's unless
you're smoking joshua
worst tv that show that you felt forced
to watch almost every episode she made
me watch the flash
it's a great series
when we first
started dating we watched almost all the
episodes if there's some good no we
didn't because you didn't like it you
didn't watch it i watched like
no you did not i tried to get you to
watch it and then you did not you were
not having it do you wanna answer that
question he wouldn't watch it at all
oh
yeah okay
how is it to be an interracial couple i
actually really like that question
because um
it is different you know uh so
it's it's a lot of learning curve i'll
say
in like depending
um on who you're with but also like
family wise
but also like culture wise you know um
i'm nepali so i have
my ethnic foods and i have you know
the culture that i come from and then
like showing him and teaching him those
things um
but it can be great i mean jake is
so open and so
um
i don't know he's he's he's very like
willing to educate himself and he's very
willing to like
be able to be open-minded about things
and i think that it can work really
great it's a beautiful thing if you're
with the right person
yeah i think you know there you have uh
you have to be real you have to be open
and listening and like i've had to be
educated about things and she's
shown me a lot about um just uh
understanding different perspectives and
everything like that um but that's it's
super important and you have to be open
and
um and that sort of thing so um yeah
yeah and i i think it's really important
even if you're not an interracial
relationship you know to just learn
about other people i think it just like
opens your world up i mean that's why i
did with my parents with me you know and
we did that through traveling which is
what i love the most about it but
yeah
well
serious question that was that was the
answer that was very serious in a very
serious way okay good job us
all right barry is amazing yes
um
no i haven't i don't play tunge in the
dragons i'm sorry um
a lot of people adore potter books in
universe but i feel like there is uh
this testimony
yeah i feel like that's
kind of where people are at where it's
like yeah you love it but i don't know
is she writing the next uh fantastic
beasts movie i don't know but i'm not a
fan of fantastic beats overall so not
really like you know it's not like it
like
takes me away from it because i just
felt like it was
wasn't as good you know
like
also it kind of i get like whole nagini
like you know the snake and harry potter
movie and her
her genesis of
where she came from and everything else
like that but like
honey just stop going through so much oh
no no keep going but like you know it's
i just i just kind of felt like
it just wasn't as good
you know i don't know i i when i saw
their previews i got excited and then
when i watched the actual movie i just
felt like it wasn't as good maybe it's
because you know harry potter like i had
the time to read it and it's part of my
childhood so
you know it was more exciting for the
movie
um
but i don't know
maybe like jk rowling could have given
it to someone else to screenwrite and
she could have written a book about it
or something else like that because i
just feel like maybe it's
it's she's not as good of a screenwriter
as she is a novelist you know so
yeah those movies have a weird structure
yeah um i haven't seen bojack you
haven't seen bloodjack horseman have you
no no um i've seen a few episodes but
it's pretty funny i like willa arnett
um
a super sticker from james harris thank
you james harris uh what james
james oh i thought you said jane for a
second i don't know maybe i did
uh it'd be funny if the super stickers
are just people typing super sticker
[Laughter]
i think that's funny but thank you
that'll definitely go towards the non
cat fun like joshua
um
right here where we're
naughty up here you've talked about this
you're married to my twin joshua
but you know i don't really like her
what are you doing oh my god just saying
he just taunts me he's saying he follows
me everywhere
i have a joshua joshua patron who
literally just taunts me all the time uh
mc's the oj of youtube in that i am an
excellent football player
good yeah um can you tell us about what
you're writing um do you want to
disclose or yes no well i think they're
talking about you or you
well i want to talk about your book i
don't um i don't want to well let's just
let's just say this i'm i have a uh
sci-fi that i'm writing that's kind of a
mix with
you know fantasy yeah
and then he's writing a fantasy
and it is really good mine is from the
uh first person
perspective i can't talk today and then
his is third
very basic info yeah um that's i i
really do like like when he graduates
college next year and i hope that like
he's at a place where he can at least be
like close to being a full-time youtuber
because i really would love for him to
like be able to share that with everyone
because it's so good like i read i read
a couple of chapters and i just couldn't
put it down and it was just really good
he's just such a good writer even when
we went to college together i always
thought he was such a great writer so
thank you it's just really good well
you know of course that makes me not
want to write because i'm like i can't
copy with this no but you know you're
honey you're so good also i mean i'm
just learning you know and it's it's
that's kind of where i'm at it's just
like i'm using whatever i'm writing is
like learning mechanism if it turns out
to be something i want to share then
i'll definitely share it but you know if
it's not
you have to you owe it you owe to share
it no no absolutely not i only want to
share something that i want i think is
you know worth sharing i think daniel
green did a great way that he you know
did his book you know published it um
have i ever met daniel in person i have
not i think we're on like opposite sides
of the country but um
maybe one day um
i will say though like one thing that i
hate about writing because i love
writing but i hate editing
oh yeah i'm i like editing yeah i i
can't stand editing at all
yeah i like to i'll edit your book that
sort of thing um yeah i like like i have
a stream of you know consciousness and i
just like put it all down in the paper
and then i just kind of don't like to
look at it but then that makes for a
really bad book so
uh flash is literal torture
[Laughter]
vindication
uh good luck or writing cats uh no no no
dogs too um
um do you wish you could ignore your
wife's comments like you nor ours
i'm not ignoring your comments i'm
reading your comments guys you're going
all over the place i'm going all over
the place because that's a method
um
did you cheat on deborah i think was
said in one video that you did want to
be partially your fault for the board
okay all right all right you know what
this is what happened no this is what
happened oh no it's okay honey we should
tell them honey honey oh they're telling
them you've involved them enough you're
stalling just tell them okay
so
they're still stolen i cheated on him
you know with joshua
and she's my twin so she was like you
know not very happy she was just like
you know
i need that kachinka ching
and then i was like no you need love
but then joshua
he like won a lottery
and then she's like i'm going with
joshua and then jake
was like
oh no
you know what you want to cheat on me
i'm going to get you back by marrying
nadia your twin
and then i was like you know what joshua
since i can't have you
i'll go with jake
and then that's how the whole thing
happened
but now i fell in love with you yeah all
right all right josh was still my true
love but you know
okay uh james harris thank you uh for
the comment that's very nice keep
growing your channel and working on it
it just takes time it honestly it does
it takes it takes it forever to to build
it but it's worth it
[Music]
um is there a character in your book
called joshua
uh
there actually might be actually i
haven't really thought about it it's a
character in my book called joshua
uh
how much time did it take to make that
haircut in the channel pick one haircut
i just guys do you know like i literally
just shave my nadia will shave my head
every every like year and then my hair
just grows back because i hate getting
haircuts
um
uh okay what is this not gonna lie your
thumbnails with your couple look like
from an assassination video where the
husband never was found
of the charge is now free by the way hi
how's it going
that's a great introduction it's a great
way to introduce yourself and yeah that
picture we were in seattle that's a fun
picture yeah i'm from seattle
oh my god i love this
oh wait wait wait pablo hold on he said
i have an exclusive guy jake's book's
titled the magical spanish civil war
yeah i did an interview with pablo you
guys can watch it i talk a little bit
about my book but it is basically
magical spanish civil war on some level
all right
nadia scares me why oh my god why i mean
why why why so many questions right
why does she scare why does she scare
you she cares me
[Laughter]
i mean she
threatens my life constantly so you know
oh my god
i just love that comment so much i love
i that that's like such a compliment to
me because i'm such a prankster that i
love
being a scary person
what's your favorite part about writing
creating a story
just creating a story yeah well
i really love uh editing like i i think
the the best part for me is like the
surprises that come with the free
writing i kind of outline and i you know
pants it a little bit
but um
my favorite part for me is yeah just the
little surprises that come that you
don't expect the little turns that a
story will take
and details that you that kind of
surprise you
yeah
okay i have to reply to this
the flash is literally the slowest
person super speed at least in the show
yes he is and there's a lot of things
about the flash that's not ideal but
what i loved about like earlier it's
definitely not gotten downhill but like
i just love the humor from it because if
you ever watch arrow
it was just such a serious show
and i like
i like having you know comedy and shows
even if it's a serious show overall so
that's what i liked about it
uh have you read red rising um
i got you ready yeah i haven't gotten to
it yet
[Music]
uh i want to read it as well though um
honey i think i wanna
i'm ready i need to go to the bathroom
so
um okay why don't you
go ahead i'll keep i'll keep the chat
roll yes
all right
now that she's gone i can really say
what i really think um
all right
all right chad get ready to go wild
nadia's nadia's in the bathroom start
stream of consciousness go go go give me
everything you got come on come on um to
me you look like some early 20th century
late 19th century american author yes
that's what i want to hear all right
more of this more of this um ever
thought of co-writing a book
uh yeah uh all the time i i um
me and pablo should co-write a book and
it'll be really
insane new video with pablo coming out
soon oh oh yeah yeah
my last question opinion on mathematics
no no thanks get that get that math out
of here i don't want to see it um
why is deborah the better than nadia um
you tell me she's not she's not you're
not better no deborah's not better
they're twins
um
how much uh do you pay nadia to pay as
your wife on stream she charges a pretty
penny all right so
the patrons are appreciated all right
um
um okay okay uh you should come to
brazil i would love to go to brazil
um now that noddy's in the bathroom you
can finally get the cat no gorb i i
won't i won't get that cat and now she's
not even here to scold me because i said
that um
today's episode's sponsored by king of
the hill um okay hold on let me do that
today's episode is sponsored by uh king
of the hill sponsored by beavis and
butthead that's pretty great has joshua
ever tried to kill you i mean he wanted
me to get the death penalty if that
counts in court
um
red rising will play yeah i i do really
want to get into red rising um i really
do
um there is a parallel plane of
existence in which i am a pancake topped
with strawberries i like thinking about
that version of me i i would like
thinking about that version of myself
too because i do think uh i i believe in
parallel universe existences i think um
i think it's a reasonable
thing that that is likely to to exist uh
why am i going to the game
why am i going to the grand canyon soon
um well i grew up in arizona i'm from
arizona so i've been to the grand canyon
several times so it's not so strange
that i would go there
with my good friend joshua
um
why oranges uh excellent excellent
question pablo oranges um why
i want to know
um
how does brandon sanderson get your zoom
link i'm pretty sure
someone on his team is a like a skilled
internet hacker um i'm just pretty sure
that's what's going on
um have i read 1122-63 i have not really
want to
um have i ever been to alcatraz and am i
the real jake uh good question how can i
know who the real jake is i mean how can
anybody know who any real person is
i have been to alcatraz i lived in san
francisco for a year
um
fun times and
alcatraz is a cool place but i was not
like uh locked up there because it's
been you know not a prison for a long
long time fun fact point blank was
filmed there right uh who is this joshua
person
if you don't know you need to find out
there's a great playlist on the channel
called the joshua saga saga and you
better better get on that stuff because
that is channel lore and it is important
you're cool but nadia's better thanks
for 9.99 to tell me that
came back at the right time
all right guys we had fun but uh this
this comment put me in my place
and uh nadia's back uh
uh with uh thank you andrew daniel for
the ten dollars not gonna lie it hurts a
little bit
that's a little bit but
it's all good
um
most importantly how oranges pablo you
are asking all of the right questions um
well brando uh will you sue brano for
stealing your zoom codes um potentially
you know uh depends uh i'm from arizona
too oh really wait where are you going
oh she's gonna make food now all right
guys all right get back come on come on
with the insane [ __ ] come on bring it on
bring it on i want to see all of your
most deranged takes let's see this [ __ ]
um
uh okay all right all right keep it up
yeah yeah yeah yeah we got this we got
this thoughts on attack
a love attack on titan haven't seen it
but i love it um
have you read c.s lewis space trilogy or
post critical essays i believe i've read
some of his essays
uh i haven't read c.s lewis space uh
trilogy but i love cs lewis uh narnia's
big favorite and uh excellent question
thanks for the five bucks um stop
talking badly about nadia she's back now
i wasn't talking bad about you they're
just saying that they're making that
[ __ ] up um insane [ __ ] thank you that's
the that's what i like to have um what
what
what
why is oranges uh even a better question
am i brando sando okay okay all right um
potentially i mean because we can't
really know for sure right
um
calm question again are you pro or
against living in space in real life oh
that's actually a kind of interesting
question i'm against living in space
because
the resources and cost it would i mean
just for humans living in spaces we
should try not to live in space uh at by
all costs but personally me i wouldn't
like to live in space because it just
sounds very uncomfortable and oh we have
a visitor
yeah
and he's wearing a attraction
yeah
he's wearing a track suit um
do you play video games
um
what oh what okay okay i'm on this guys
don't worry don't lose faith in me
why not apples i want to read 1984
should i read the prequels oh that's a
really good question uh j.r lewis is
overrated yeah good call um
i can murder any fictional main
character uh who is it in the lash come
on don't even um read this one yeah yeah
yeah um um uh do you play video games i
love mario starring chris pratt uh
that's the only one i i know and that's
the only one i'm aware of
um
do you know any nepalese
yes i do i speak it i know a few words
phrases
what some rude phrases say how to say
how to say i love you uh my teammate de
la maya got you yeah
see ah
that's awesome
uh i'm so cool um real question though
are you a gamer guys would i lie to my
gamer fans come on i i'm on gamers i'm a
gamer
kind of well i used to be what
do you have a gamer chair
do you see do you say what's up gamers
when you walk into a room every time i
go like this
yeah she's not a gamer um
uh does your book contain a scene where
joshua's being tortured uh i think i
should i think that'd be very
therapeutic for me but i i go to therapy
for that mostly
um is it okay if adeline is my favorite
character very understandable you know
you like to [ __ ] and shardplay it's fine
it's cool we've all been there
uh
why was daniel right to make that book
covered he wasn't all right that was
clear uh violence on the books it's just
not
not cool um
uh
okay okay true story story oranges are
my personal phobia i'm feeling angry
attacked right now i'm so sorry oranges
look i'm not a fan of oranges that pablo
was the one bringing up oranges in the
first place
and so that's kind of where i'm at with
i don't know i don't like the texture i
like orange juice no pulp though don't
don't come at me with that stupid what
do you how do you feel about pulp
i like pulp don't even
all right
have it
what i don't know what that is um
okay uh some appeal okay i saw
our opinions on politics out so i'm
gonna cover this someone else asked
about my personal religious opinions
beliefs um i don't have a bunch of fully
formed uh religious beliefs but uh
politics i'm
politics
am i right
come on guys
come on very great answer come on gamers
we know politics all right we got
someone else uh with the the the the oh
crazy fan takes we love crazy fan takes
yeah stream with nadia oh should i
okay should i thanks i'm glad that
everyone has that opinion five dollars
you know what thanks and you know what
um
i will put that five dollars towards the
cat just because it's it's not yet what
yeah
uh no pulp bro i am disgusted pulp or
nothing don't don't no no guys guys
where is this coming from i thought you
guys were gamers please don't do this to
me
um what fantasy genre are you oh i'm
totally like um
historical fantasy genre that's my
it's my jam
um
hello mister
please hand over your television license
what is happening
daniel violated
yeah he did uh will you take any legal
actions against daniel um i don't think
i can as i'm currently living in exile
in mexico
um don't blame me i brought up apples
yeah apples are great uh it's not the
soft ones don't eat apples when they're
all soft
you know
will you run for president again uh not
sure if i can depending on um you know
the laws maybe the laws will change i
can come back to the states we'll see
um
joshua seems like the person to falsely
copyright claim your videos it totally
does
um totally does
pope is me no guy okay
this is just
we are all gamers today we're all gamers
uh god bless us gamers uh you know we i
know this is a book channel but uh gamer
gamers gamers gamer gamer gamer gamer
gamer gamergamer gamergamer gamer all
right uh will you wear wigs um
why not i mean why not
uh what does a man have to do for a
sprite sponsorship
um yeah i've been thinking about that a
lot lately because sprite i i've been
kind of i've been actively courting
their money
[Laughter]
uh
okay seven eaves is awesome definitely
mustard i don't even know about that i
have to write that down and get that um
no oj only g fuel yeah exactly
i see you more as absurdist fantasy uh
why so ever would you think that um
uh that was
a joke i i know what you mean um
if you had to gain 10 or 20 pounds what
would you eat what do you mean had to
i'll just do that any day come on um all
right what would i eat uh cookies every
day and night uh pancakes for breakfast
i'm has have an insane sweet tooth i
don't know what would you eat oh we got
another um
cat one
thanks thanks for the for the money but
um that's uh an offensive question and i
i love that question cat maybe in like
i would say by the end
of the what what
we'll see how pushy you guys do all you
guys is fun i like that uh i like that
username greed
why greedy you know makes you think it
makes you think it makes you laugh it
makes you think you're laughing right
um
i'm glad nadia is slowly taking over the
channel she's so much better than that
jake guy nadia coop
you say coop
that's why i'm funny because i say it
you say it wrong yeah
uh
we are gay not gamers hey that's
that's wonderful i think all gamers
all
all
every type of gamer are welcome and we
are all gamers today um
yes cat
what
will you wear wigs what is okay what is
with wig what are t
what are people talking about do you
think i need a wig or something
um
no i think you should donate oh you're
left or snow yeah i am i am and uh
gamers rise up leftism let's we got this
um uh jacob please i'm begging you
please give me a smoothie maker
i don't know if you're aware i'm not
like an etsy shop or um
sharper image but um i don't know email
me i'll i'll see if i can get you a
smoothie maker out i don't know i'll
inquire
uh i don't know who i'll ask who should
i ask
that's
i don't understand
um
oh i missed the first hour how are you
all what i'm not gonna answer that
question you missed the first hour what
does this look like charity hour i'm not
gonna i'm not gonna tell you you gotta
catch up on the lore okay
gee whiz you missed so much
how dare you
um
this is a minecraft channel though isn't
it obviously i mean obviously
gamergamergamer yes thank you um
both of you best horror movies for the
spooky season oh man uh i mean we just
we just watched scream i never saw
scream before the original thought it
was funny and horror scream was great um
i want to watch the new halloween
um
oh yeah the new halloween is going to be
good also
at least um i want to i've been like
obsessed with john john carpenter movies
um
so i've been watching john carpenter
um
you know what's funny when i was younger
like preteen i used to think lord of the
rings was so scary
it is this orcs are scary as hell i
thought it was the return of the king
the guy i was like with the dragon i was
like so scared
sprite or arby's uh again another great
match up constantly
constantly thinking about this um i'm
gonna go with sprite probably favorite
dinosaur brachiosaur that's a dinosaur
right
what is your favorite
are you ordering food right now yeah
we have why are you ordering food
we're streaming we're gamers i guess
gamers can order food right i want food
all right order food let's let's order
should we order food guys yes or no yeah
you guys can't have any
oh my goodness you want thai food uh no
you want chipotle ooh yeah chipotle
guys chipotle yeah gamers
um
all right imagine you got put on the
jedi council but not granted the rank of
jedi master what would you do i'd kill a
bunch of kids obviously come on guys i
know i know what i know what to do in
those situations
um
uh have they do have the meats arby's
has the meats but guess what
vegan vegetarian that's right yeah yeah
complain all you want you could have
impossible meat yeah well we could have
but i don't know carlos jr has it now i
wouldn't trust it um
jacob can you please play bookworm
adventures deluxe i would be more than
happy to
uh what's your favorite house plant if
you have any that one over there you
guys know the one
um
nadia usurper um yeah
that is so true what
i like chipotle
until i saw thai food now i don't know
what i want anymore chipotle
guys chipotle or thai food please can
you just solve this for us
or italian
or pizza chipotle has the breakfast of
gamers
all right chipotle i'm making you so
hungry uh i'm sorry we're making
hungry but chipotle
rice and beans and vegetables gamers can
only order food cooking is forbidden
yeah that's true chipotle is yeah we
we're gut chipotle gamers need fuel uh
did viggo actually cry tears of joy
because he finally hit you and the toe
story is just told to humanize him
yeah a lot of those stories are told to
humanize him he was a monster on set he
was trying to kick that head right
towards my head trying to okay he broke
a couple toes all right boo hoo he was
trying to decapitate me with a freaking
orc head all right
you guys need to watch the video all
right it'll explain so much
um let's open the malazan themed
restaurant you have good luck with that
i'm sure that's going to find a lot of
i'm sorry
that'd be interesting if there's going
to be a themed restaurant let's make it
um
let's make it um
um
minecraft themed come on guys come on
gamers
um vegans for president um
yeah i i would i'm down with that
chipotle okay
chipotle no we're not doing italian no
don't say time don't say thai don't say
hi tai
wait a second i haven't ordered it yet
thai food okay when will you review we
got tied just the other night are you
kidding me so we'll have it again when
will you review the minecraft books also
thai food no no no thai food
should i review the minecraft books
that's a good question okay i see more
thai food thai pizza thai japanese okay
i think thai food won
i want to see you eating
the hell pretty sure typhoon won honey
i don't want thai food fine chipotle it
is
call compromise i thought you wanted to
i thought you wanted chipotle
i was fine with chipotle until i saw
thai food now it looks the only thing is
you have to pick up if it's chipotle
oh i can't do that
in like an hour oh i got a minute no i
can pick it up i can pick it up i have
to end the stream sorry guys
um
that's what you get for voting for
chipotle
i think there's like a seven dollar off
promotion if you pick it up
uh i don't know if the lore of this
channel can someone explain chipotle
like a secret password
yeah it is it's a secret password
of to my heart
um
prove you're a gamer what's the
best-selling game um i'm pretty sure the
best-selling game is uh gex um
uh what is deborah's favorite place to
order food from oh man i don't know she
she's
you're not deborah you don't know she's
my twin i know her
did you order yes
that's right chipotle guys
uh today i learned chipotle is
pronounced chipotle
oh
my mom pronounces it chipote i pronounce
it chipotle
does nadia know about your third family
um i don't try to what do you want to do
no i don't
try to get into that i don't i don't i
don't guys guys don't talk about that
uh ty or you get the cat this is getting
out of hand we ordered already all right
you know what since we didn't order thai
food i guess we just have to get a
carrot all right when i said gamers rise
up i didn't mean rise up against me
um are you both religious uh sorry if
this is in your face question
don't apologize all questions are
welcome i mean my gamers are are welcome
here in the chat
um i'm not i'm not religious
are you looking at me you know
you just want me to speak for myself
catholic i i don't know
uh i'm not religious but i respect all
religion respect all religion yeah
except for the ones that that are you
know
harm people
um
obviously talking about scientology
what
we watch like the uh show the aftermath
of scientology chipotle oh it's
interesting
chipotle it's pronounced chipotle
favorite writing incident um
the blood from uh an ancient book this
is my favorite writing instrument i go
like this and i put his hand and i go
i get like nothing done and it takes you
a long time to write
but that's how we do it oh we can't
change it
um chipotle these nuts on your face
well i appreciate this so sorry it's
like you it's like see these this is the
respect i get from my gamers am i right
this is what gamers do they'll do this
[ __ ] but then they'll say so sorry and i
appreciate it like when you kill someone
and you go so sorry that i have to do
this
philosophy opinions of you know
philosophy it's there love those
philosophies you know what uh norm
macdonald died recently i love nor
macdonald but he
one of his quotes that i love is that
people say that you know comedians are
the modern day philosophers which you
know is a huge insult to modern day
philosophers
um i always like that i don't know what
this has to do with it but philosophy is
very fascinating i i don't have any i
don't really have any foundational
beliefs in anything i just kind of go
with the whims of uh the chaos that is
the universe um i don't know how you
feel about that but i just i don't you
know
you know
i feel badly about it okay
um
respect all religion just like gamers
respect all women yeah absolutely
um 2049 is my favorite sci-fi movie ever
um believe it or not i actually haven't
seen it i don't know why i really like
the original blade runner i just i don't
know i've been pushing it off because
i'm worried i won't like it but
uh
if she breathed is she a thought no
that's not that's not a gamer attitude
come on
uh do you write like stories yeah i
write like stories i wrote a script
recently um we were just talking about
this
um
when are you guys going to watch naruto
or one piece of booktuber um wonderful
channel um
i don't know i wanna i wanna read one
should i read or watch one piece i wanna
read it first
okay
okay um hi
hi hi
hi
okay you're not even a real gaming fan
name three of their songs uh oh my
gatekeeping that's what i'm talking
about
we stand gatekeeping
not really don't take that out of
context please read one piece okay
all right
uh
should we compare a counter revolution
to nadio's coup yes
prepare counter revolution send
resources um who knows i mean next week
maybe uh there'll just only be strictly
an audio videos and you'll be going well
what happened to what happened to jake
and i'll just be off the face of the
earth it could happen any time so
appreciate me cherish me gamers
you don't know how long you'll have me
for
um have i read kreiden yeah i love
michael cricht i read uh jurassic park
and the lost world in uh middle school i
think
good books i really love those jurassic
park is way more gruesome than the movie
uh the book is
um
let's see we got to install microwave
ovens
what does that mean
what does that mean i mean again i'm
reading this out of context but
um
i hope everyone has a great one uh god
bless just kid just kidding take care um
bro can you read blade runner 2069
this is a gamer move that's such a gamer
thing to say
uh utilitarianism gang yeah yeah do all
the dogs go to the tranquiline halls of
course they're the first ones to go
they're the first ones to go read one
piece for sure okay
uh 100 read dune is so good it might be
my favorite sci-fi uh don't know for
sure though yeah you need to read dunes
still right yes yes
i'm gonna watch the movie first
oh come on
oh is that's the guy who said should i
like watch one piece or read it first
pineapple or pizza yeah or nah yeah i'm
i'm partial to it i don't need it but he
doesn't he didn't like it before when we
started eating but i brainwashed
i like pineapple and pizza now um
what is happening what is happening guys
can can we can we can someone inspect
chat and figure out where this started
with wearing wigs what is what is going
on
um
what are you doing sidoni okay uh this
is getting disgruntling if that's a word
uh nadia will you oh wait
chat moved i was gonna how did you meet
we're gonna do a video about that oh
yeah we're totally going to do a video
you'll you'll see
yeah it's going to blow your minds uh
nadia will you make this an anime
channel will you take over
hope you guys like dragon ball z
oh yeah wuthering heights why is it so
bad let's is this enough common opinion
about wuthering heights
have you read whether i haven't read it
so
um i can't speak on it
uh
have i already came up i don't know what
that is but i would love to be informed
gamers come on
um oh it's ready for pickup oh guys
food's ready for pickup you know what
that means i obviously prioritize my
gamers
more than any anything but
when chipotle calls
come on guys
so
we've been here for an hour and a half i
mean that's i think that's our longest
stream we've done yeah yeah
something about saturdays just so chill
this was a nice fun stream
i think sometimes like the streaming on
sunday is more chaotic
i wish i could answer more questions
guys but again i gotta get food
so
this has been fun thank you for everyone
who showed up it was lovely to hear
uh everyone's voices through text and um
yeah this is just awesome so thank you
everyone's voices through text i don't
know what i'm saying i'm delusional
guys i'm hungry um
so um yeah i think do you have any last
words is this a song hungry like a wolf
i'm on the hunt i'm after you
do
[Music]
stop it we'll get copyright strikes for
our amazing singing
all right um
anti-hierarchy hell yeah anarchism let's
go um
game lit our book and
that was
serious that was sincere um
all right please uh okay great uh
sentiment to end the stream on so thank
you guys
um i'm sorry they'll break your legs
just again i guess contact me i'll try
to help you out there
um thank you for having me on man caring
oh i mean thank you for letting me
and follow his instagram so that i can
guys go on instagram i'm i'm an
influencer yeah i'm an influencer
i can i can put like embarrassing posts
for him okay
well love you all take care um and do do
good do good in this world don't harm
others just eat chipotle
i i mean and if you don't want don't
have one near you make it
love each other be nice
spread love now don't don't cheat on
your partner don't cheat on your wallet
with anyone don't cheat it's bad the
only reason i'm saying that it's only
because joshua's reserved for me time to
pay nadia for actually i i do that after
after the stream but thank you all right
thanks guys
bye bye